many people force out of their homes by
Harvey are facing big new challenges as
they return to see the destruction
emergency officials say the storm
destroyed more than a thousand homes in
Texas about 50,000 more are damaged Kris
Van Cleave is in Crosby Texas northeast
of Houston where he witnessed some
heartbreaking
homecomings Kris good morning good
morning the water is slowly receding
here it's down about a foot in the last
12 hours but at its peak it reached
about midway up the door of this car
water going down is a good thing but
really it's just the start of the
problems facing many thousands of people
across Southeast Texas Jose and Maribel
Garcia have taken the trip down in
patchy lane to their home every day for
the past 19 years but this time it's in
their neighbors boat this your house
yeah
it's the first time back since Hurricane
Harvey hit but they couldn't get in
because they lost the key to the house
the Garcias didn't have high water gear
so we waited through chest deep water to
help get through their back window
inside it's worse than they fear what's
going through your mind and you walked
in here the couple lives here with four
of their adult children and one grandkid
a babies bottle and food sit unfinished
on the counter reminders of how quickly
they had to get out as the water was
rising people park their cars on the
streets thinking it was high enough but
the water kept coming it was a
heartbreaking homecoming for many
families in Crosby gone on hell Balderas
lives down the street he had to canoe to
his house during the storm his family
woke up to three feet of water inside
their home and just had to go what's in
his truck bed is all he could salvage
what about like the baby pictures the
family photos yeah we got her we got
some of it saved out but not much
everything is almost gone Maribel was
only able to find enough dry clothes for
a couple of days it's hard to imagine
that will be possible anytime soon so
for now they'll stay with family I just
feel overwhelmed a feeling shared by so
many around here as they come home to
find there's not much to come home to
estimates show more than 80% of people
in this area with water damage do not
have flood insurance no one we talked to
has any flood insurance which means they
may be on their own when it comes to
paying for repairs
Maurice heartbreak and Chris thank you